oh yeah yes it's fun we don't see you a
little more often because you guys shoot
two and a Half Men literally like seven
feet from here yes I think I'd see you
at the burrito truck all the time you'd
think you but I do not I'm not into the
burrito no you do not like them sadly
and I don't like you combination
combination really good slash burrito
that doesn't go too well
combo platter I sure hunt you down I'll
find you more on the on the lot I will
as well I got to ask you about something
which seemed like a very high honor to
me I was looking through the recent
issue of Vanity Fair and they were
covering this paramount the 100-year the
centennial party for Paramount Pictures
and they invited all the stars that had
been involved in Paramount over the
years huge names nutty nutty fantastic
and I mean some of the biggest stars in
the world and you are in the picture why
yes you mean what's five years look
around there's a really you're really
I'm right next to the red haired lady
that would be Molly Ringwald where where
there
oh my god okay oh my gosh it's time for
the time for the crew to get their
glaucoma test that's so you look very
happy there I just have to ask you one
question cuz I'm looking at this picture
earlier and I was like I saw Robert
DeNiro
he looks really pissed off about their
other one else is thrilled to be there
and he looks like he's waiting for a bus
that's late just so you know the the
porta-potties were really nasty nice so
was this Photoshop did they really get
you all together they got us all
together it was it was ridiculous they
had told me all these people were coming
and I I didn't kind of believe it and
then you get to the the Hat little
cocktail party before and I'm sitting
there with my diet coke just in the
corner and how are you doing this well
because you kind of have to hunker down
right big stars in Hoffman then there
isn't Ford and who wears an earring
weird super strange and you could not
throw a rock in that room without
hitting Don Cheadle
it was the expression you don't get to
use very hot very often cheaters
okay sounds like sounds like he gained
300 but a lovely man at any rate it was
it was truly remarkable to be in that
room
simon pegg and i who your city simon
pegg was sitting right next to me and
we're wondering in this kind of group
how on earth as you saw it was hard to
find us and so we're trying to figure
out how on earth to get everybody's
attention and we figured when they
actually took the shot instead of posing
than because he all had to kind of adopt
some sort of pose right that we would
pose like this here were the two dead
guys in the shot